Dr. Blast and his group of researchers stand
behind bulletproof viewing glass.
They all have very serious looks on their
faces, that is until the first test begins.
On one side of the test room a Class-D subject
stands holding a sheet of paper; on the other
side sits a bright red tomato on a wooden
table.
Dr. Blast pushes the intercom button and speaks
into the microphone: “alright, you may begin.”
D-504-1 nods and looks down at the sheet of
paper in his hand.
He begins to read.
"Is a hippopotamus a hippopotamus or just
a really cool opotamous?"
Nothing happens.
D-504-1 stands there awkwardly waiting.
A man next to Dr. Blast in the observation
room snickers.
Dr. Blast jerks his head towards the researcher
and stares him down.
“This is not a laughing matter,” Blast
says.
The reprimanded researcher clears his throat
and stands up straight.
“Sorry sir.”
Dr. Blast leans over and pushes the microphone
button again.
“Proceed to the next joke D-504-1.”
The man on the other side of the glass nods
and pulls a second sheet of paper out from
behind the first.
"What's an archaeologist?
Someone whose career is in ruins," says D-504-1.
A moment after he finishes the joke, the ripe
red tomato launches itself off of the table
and flies towards the face of D-504-1.
The tomato is clocked at moving 104 miles
per hour.
D-504-1 has no time to move before the tomato
slams into his nose, instantly breaking it.
The men in the observation room behind the
bulletproof glass do their best to hold back
their laughter.
Dr. Blast grumbles as he jots down notes on
his clipboard.
“It appears that SCP-504 has a certain "taste"
in jokes,” he says to the rest of the researchers
in the room, this elicits a slight chuckle.
“This might indicate sapience.
I hope not.
Clean the room and bring in the next subject.”
Medical personnel and a team of custodial
staff enter the room.
The physicians tend to D-504-1’s nose and
carry him out, the custodians clean the remnants
of tomato off the floor, walls, and ceiling.
They exit, leaving the room completely empty.
A moment later the door opens and another
ordinary looking tomato is brought in and
placed on the desk.
The SCP agent who brought in the tomato leaves.
D-504-2 enters the room a moment later with
a sheet of paper in his hand.
He stands on the far side of the room away
from the SCP-504 tomato sitting on the table.
He nervously brings the paper closer to his
face to read what’s on it.
“Three tomatoes are walking down the street,”
D-504-2 says with a little shake in his voice.
He had seen D-504-1 exit the room just before
he entered, with blood and tomato paste running
down his face.
“A papa tomato, a mama tomato, and a little
baby tomato.
Baby tomato starts lagging behind.
Papa tomato gets angry, goes over to the baby
tomato, and smushes him… and says, catch
up."
The new SCP-504 tomato immediately goes flying
from the table straight towards the joke teller.
This time the tomato is clocked at 264 miler
per hour when it slams into the face of D-504-2
The impact immediately renders him unconscious.
After the first few trials Dr. Blast decides
that it is time to take things up a notch.
The Foundation has collected hundreds of SCP-504
tomatoes, so there is no shortage.
After the room is cleaned once again, and
a medical team removes the unconscious Class-D
personnel who was knocked out by the previous
SCP-504 experiment, they are ready to begin
again.
This time there will be terrible consequences
for their actions.
D-504-3 enters the room.
The SCP-504 tomato has already been placed
on the table.
“You may begin,” Dr. Blast says into the
microphone.
The Class-D personnel reads the joke on the
sheet of paper he is holding.
"So, I was going to bed, and my brother told
me, 'Goodnight!
Don't let the bedbugs stick their proboscis
in your skin and suck your blood!”
D-504-3 pauses for a beat.
"Good luck on a healthy dermis!” he ends
the joke.
For two seconds there is no reaction from
SCP-504.
Dr. Blast thinks this terrible joke just wasn’t
one that SCP-504 could understand.
Suddenly there is a loud crack!
D-504-3 falls to the floor; tomato covers
where his face once was.
When Dr. Blast and the other researchers go
back and slow down the video, they witness
the SCP-504 tomato traveling so quickly that
it broke the sound barrier.
The tomato impacted the joke teller at an
unfathomable speed, instantly killing him.
Dr. Blast decides that he needs to be more
careful when choosing jokes for the safety
of everyone involved.
Perhaps a crossbreed between SCP-504 and regular
tomatoes will yield different results.
After the unfortunate death of D-504-3 the
research team waits a few days before experimenting
with the new strains of SCP-504.
Three different crossbreeds are brought into
the room and placed equidistant from each
other on the table.
D-504-4 enters the room.
Dr. Blast presses the intercom button and
orders him to begin.
"If you have dentures, don't use artificial
sweetener, cause you'll get a fake cavity,”
says D-504-4.
The moment the joke ends all three tomatoes
launch towards him at 145 miles per hour.
They hit him square in the face.
Two teeth are dislodged; the test subject
is covered in the remains of the three squashed
tomatoes.
“Interesting,” notes Dr. Blast.
“All of the tomatoes reacted in the same
way, so now we know multiple instances of
SCP-504 will go after the same joke maker.”
He pauses to think for a moment.
“What if we cut up the tomatoes?”
The test room is reset.
Another SCP-504 tomato is brought in and cut
up into quarters.
D-504-5 enters the room and begins his joke.
“I tried to walk into Target, but I missed.”
All four pieces of the tomato speed towards
D-504-5’s face.
They slam into him at 212 miles per hour.
One of the pieces of tomatoes impales itself
into his eye, instantly destroying it.
The medical team rushes in and removes the
howling subject from the room.
Dr. Blast writes vigorously on his clipboard.
“We are starting to go through test subjects
too quickly,” he announces.
“Let’s try a recording and see if SCP-504
will react to that.”
The research team brings in a new tomato,
a CD player, and the "Harmful If Swallowed"
album by Dane Cook
The CD begins to play.
During one of the jokes the tomato launches
itself off the table and slams into the CD
player, causing both the stereo and the tomato
to shatter into several pieces.
The tomato was clocked at 167 miles per hour.
“It would appear that SCP-504 reacts to
recordings as well.
We didn’t even have to deal with the damned
class-D’s in the first place,” says Dr.
Blast.
He informs his team that since the risk level
is now relatively low, they can continue the
experiments without him.
He leaves the observation room to get some
rest.
The other researchers look at one another,
mischievous smiles cross their faces as they
begin to laugh.
The SCP-504 research team sets up three new
tomatoes and brings three Class-D subjects
into the room.
The researchers then retreat back into the
observation area and begin a joke over the
intercom system while the Class-D personnel
wait patiently in the room with the SCP-504
tomatoes.
“The following news item has just been released,”
said one of the researchers over the intercom
system.
“Bomb blows hole in Lenin statue.”
The first test subject finishes the joke with
the ending written on his sheet of paper:
“Ooh, that's gonna leave a Marx,” test
subject 1 says.
The first tomato twitches, but does not leave
its location on the table.
The second test subject reads from his paper:
“BBC is just Stalin the good news.”
The second tomato leaves the table at 152
miles per hour and slams into the jaw of the
second test subject causing a hairline fracture
and a chipped tooth.
The third test subject looks at the ending
to the joke on his paper and begins to shake
nervously.
He speaks two words, which he knows will not
end well for him.
“That blows.”
The third SCP-504 tomato flies off the table,
slams into the third test subject's head,
and instantly knocks him out.
The test subject is sent to the hospital with
a massive skull fracture.
The next day Dr. Blast bursts into the observation
room and reprimands the research team.
“I thought we'd just established that recordings
work in place of live subjects!” screams
Dr. Blast.
“I know how much you guys hate the Class-Ds,
especially D-504-012, but the poor guy might
not even recover before his termination rolls
around.
I'm making it clear right now that whoever
oversaw this round of testing is getting a
serious reprimand.
The same goes for whoever leaked its video
logs to the staff!”
Everyone is silent, from somewhere within
the group of research there is a snicker,
then they all break out into laughter.
After this incident no Class-Ds, or other
personnel, are used in the research being
conducted on SCP-504.
The research team wheels in a television playing
the Sarah Palin and Hillary Clinton SNL skit
The tomato shows signs of confusion as it
flies off the table.
Its trajectory includes three separate bursts
of speed over 200 mile per hour, two stretches
of motion at normal throwing speed, and one
unprecedented instance of the tomato moving
backwards.
This all occurs during the flight of a single
SCP-504 tomato during the SNL skit.
The working hypothesis is that the tomato
was unsure whether to take the video seriously
or not.
The research team later finds out that SCP-504
really hates science and mathematics jokes
when they bring in a laptop that plays a pre-recorded
engineering joke.
Over the speakers a mechanical voice can be
heard saying: “2009 is going to be a complex
year.
We already know the real part; we still have
to find the imaginary part.”
At the conclusion of the joke there is a supersonic
blast and the computer is completely vaporized
by the tomato's kinetic energy.
The sensors recorded an approximate speed
of 2,174 mile per hour as the tomato flew
across the room.
The conclusion of the experiments on SCP-504
end with another computer being brought into
the test room.
The computer begins to play the Monty Python
sketch of "The Funniest Joke in the World.”
Towards the end of the skit the Allied forces
are reciting the funniest joke in the world
in German to defeat the Nazi’s.
The actors chant: “Wenn ist das Nunstruck
git und Slotermeyer?
Ja!
Beiherhund das Oder die Flipperwaldt gersput!”
At the end of the joke the tomato explodes
on the table where it once sat.
Debris from the tomato coats the entire room
including the computer.
The researchers conclude that SCP-504 did
not know what to do with “The Funniest Joke
in the World,” so it self-terminated.
Dr. Blast sits in the cafeteria quietly eating
his lunch reading over the logs for the SCP-504
experiments.
Suddenly a commotion breaks out in the kitchen.
There are screams of terror.
Dr. Blast jumps out of his seat, runs to the
kitchen door, and pushes it open.
To his surprise he sees slices of tomatoes
flying around the room.
Someone on the research team thought it’d
be funny to give the unknowing kitchen staff
SCP-504 tomatoes to see what would happen.
After they had been cut up and put into the
food for the day, someone in the kitchen told
a bad joke; the tomato slices flew around
like shurikens.
Dr. Blast sees a group of researchers peering
through a kitchen window and laughing hysterically.
He will get to the bottom of which researchers
did this, and they will be fired from The
SCP Foundation.
Now watch “SCP-001 - Atonement - Ouroboros
Cycle (SCP Animation).”
Or check out “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation (SCP Animation).”